FOR THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE EAD
ADVISER AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BE MADE AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTEND THE
HEARING MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES ATTENDEES WILL SOLVE
REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE TO ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS- MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HERE AND HERE AND THAT
OFFENSE LARA YOU HAVE BEEN HERE
WE MAIENSCHEIN HERE AFFECT YOUR
LONG HERE RUBIO. YEAH WALK HERE
THE PARK WE HAVE A QUORUM OF WE
HAVE A CAN AGENDA FOR MOST OF
RIVER MATH SECULAR BY MRGIPSON.
OF MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY. AYE AYE CUNNINGHAM
AND IT ALSO FOR YOURSELF ALL
RIGHT IT'S ENTIRELY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS RIGHT
AFTER TYRONE LIKE FOREMOST BY
RADIO HI RUBIO MARK TO LOG BACK
LOCK BY. THE MOTION IS PROUD
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING ME
THIS IS MIKE. SIT HERE FOR
MINUTES.
LARA I. THANK YOU- GOOD
. NO OTHER PACK YOUR PHYSICAL
AND YOUR- YEAH. FOR CALLING ON
THE RADIO THIS COMMITTEE ISN'T.